JOSHUA GUNN: One
thing I thought was
effective was the way
that Chris, I think,
on the first day I attended and
watched, you kind
of laid out a sort
of more theoretical framework
you know about storytelling
and that sort of thing.
And I think that was
nice because, for me, I
think it's effective.
I'm just one kind of
learner, but sort of
have a sort of theory laid out
first, and then practice later.
I got the big idea
of the why and then
it felt to me like the course
dove into some of the details
of how.
So it was was like a theory
practice kind of structure,
which would have been
quite useful to me
had I taken the whole course.
CHRIS BOEBEL: One of the
big challenges, I think,
with any kind of media
course or film, video, is it
that the technical stuff is
so overwhelming, potentially,
for people who are new.
There's such a
big learning curve
that you can get lost in
those details really fast.
And you go, oh my God,
I'll never learn Final Cut
and why does everything
I shoot suck?
Oh, this is terrible,
I'm a failure.
And if you kind of go,
well, those aren't really
the learning objectives, which
you very clearly articulated,
then it's kind of
a bigger un-clench.
It's like, OK, what I'm
really learning here is to be
a communicator, be a
storyteller, carry myself,
understand this medium,
and maybe someday I'll be
a terrific editor,
or maybe I won't.
But either waw--
JOSHUA GUNN: Maybe you'll
plug into the processes
in some other way.
CHRIS BOEBEL: In some other way.
Exactly, yeah.
But you have to understand
the whole process.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I
remember when I first
proposed like-- because
you were like, what
do you want me to do?
Because I was just like, can
you be involved in this somehow?
And it was sort of
like, well, maybe
you could cover
the actual basics
of shooting and everything.
You said something like, they
seem like a technical things.
And I was like, oh
shoot, this is terrible.
I'm doing the thing that
I tell people not to do.
So we made a very
conscious decision
to take all this
technical elements.
We did not teach how to edit
on Final Cut or anything.
Instead, MIT has free
Window licensing.
And honestly, their videos
teach it better than I do.
I don't know Final Cut
well enough to teach it.
And not all the
students used it,
so we said, for all the
technical learning stuff,
it was all on digital
blended learning.
Flip Classroom.
Thank you.
And class time was really about
teaching big picture stuff,
and then work shopping specific
examples, and specific things
they came up with.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Because
time is limited
and it's so daunting
to become a director,
on camera host, writer,
editor, camera person, all
in a few weeks.
And it's just not
going to happen.
JOSHUA GUNN: Just
the expectation
that they come out with
the notion of storytelling
would be sufficient.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
It really ended up
being a class on pre-production.
It was like two weeks of
intense scripting and planning
and the rest just
sort of happened
in the last couple days.
The just had to figure
out how to film.
JOSHUA GUNN: That's great, I
mean the technical execution
gets pushed to the margin,
and the more creative stuff
takes precedence.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I mean
it's a different class.
There were a couple
people who dropped
because they came in thinking,
like, this is going to be
a class on how to make a video.
And it's not exactly about that.
Because there are
other classes like that
that already exist
on campus, so there's
no reason for us to redo that.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: And
you learn stuff
by like shooting your own
stuff and screwing up.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah, exactly.
ELIZABETH CHOE: But
if someone's going
to watch this class on
OpenCourseWare, for instance,
they're not necessarily going
to pick up the practical skills
that they might be expecting to.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: We don't teach
you how to light, sorry.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
But like a teacher
who might be watching this
might be like, how do I
teach a video production class?
And I'm not sure this is
necessarily exactly that.
Sorry.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Oops.
But it is hopefully maybe
a conceptual framework
that you could then plug-in
production modules into.
JOSHUA GUNN: Or a larger course.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah,
it was so short.
It felt like a sprint.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah
what can you do?
What can you accomplish
in that time?
I was impressed by
how ambitious it was.
CHRIS BOEBEL: It was very
ambitious, I thought.